you  three and a quarter miles east of Key  Biscayne near Miami Florida is an  underwater eternal resting place for  ocean lovers the Neptune Memorial Reef  is an artificial man-made reef that  houses the remains of thousands of  people after cremation ashes are mixed  with cement to form features that become  part of the reef  the reefs design was inspired by the  underwater city Atlantis and includes  lion statues columns benches canopies  and podiums it takes up half an acre and  six forty feet under the surface of the  water the Neptune memorial reef serves a  dual purpose as a home to many  underwater creatures fulfilling its  mission of creating life after life  [Music]  you